[Musique]
j'aimerais vous parler de mes deux
passions un premier patient qui fait
qu'avancer il ya quarante ans ça fait 40
ans que je travaille sur le cerveau
j'essaie de comprendre comment le
cerveau marche spécifiquement comment
notre cerveau permet de reconnaître des
objets des soldes sont un très
rapidement et en plus comment peut-on
fabriquer un système artificiel inspiré
de comment marche le cerveau mais le
deuxième passion ses plus récents ça
fait depuis 10 2010 que je m'intéresse
beaucoup à l'économie
et comment construire une société qui
marche pour tous je vais essayer de vous
convaincre les deux choses sont faites
mélange est donc déjà mes recherches sur
leur vision ultra rapide
voilà quelques illustrations de on peut
reconnaître des centaines de milliers
d'objets de façon totalement automatique
comme ça la question c'est comment ça
marche
eh bien il ya un climat
il y à peu près 30 ans je me suis rendu
compte que les latences daignera long au
du système visuel peu près sont mes deux
secondes mais des contraintes énormes
sur le mode de traitement et on gros il
va falloir que un image flashy sous la
rétine traves traversent ces différentes
couches de traitement en une seule vague
avec en plus c'est le des impulsions à
chaque niveau qui sont utilisés pour que
des désinformations et plutôt l'autre
dans lesquelles ces impulsions des
sprites qui est utilisé comme code on a
utilisé ses ses idées pour un créer une
société supra xact technology qu'on a
créé en 15 99 avec mes deux étudiants
alors sprague n'at-il pas mal mais
franchement c'était pas le niveau du
système visuel humain et je croyais pas
que ça allait arriver
mais en fait des systèmes artificiels
qui sont aussi bons que l'être humain il
faille existe déjà une machine il ya un
défi qui s'appelle et b jean est
où on donne aux chercheurs 10 millions
de l'image appartements des milliers de
catégories vous entraînez votre système
et à la fin on vous donne plein de
l'image nouvelle et il faut les
identifier et à gauche ici tous ces
points en 2010 assez les performances
des systèmes de vision des plus
classiques de vision et puis le monde a
changé ici en 2012 à pas et ces deux
étudiants à 38 ans il a développé un
truc qui s'appelle super jeu qui est en
fait c'est juste tout bêtement série de
couches de niro exactement quand j'avais
10 à 30 ans donc j'avais un peu raison
que je dirais ce système en fête permet
de reconnaître plaindre des milliers des
millions de l'image de façon vraiment
que moment précis alors jackson et ses
étudiants de deux étudiants au fond
d'une boîte dr rush achetée l'année
après gbagbo pour les centaines de
millions de dollars et depuis il n'ya
que ce type de système c'est que dès ce
que des systèmes dit dit planning ça a
complètement transformé la demande en
on était un être humain pouvait faire
encore mieux ça c'est le performance en
être humain 94% correct mais vous voyez
que dès 2015
on est dépassé les machines sur des
architectes très simple comme ça dépasse
notre capacité de reconnaître des objets
alors vu la simplicité de ce traitement
c'est vraiment juste un série d'ailleurs
deux couches de neuf ans après l'autre
les gens se sont mis à fabriquer des
puces électroniques
1 pour reproduire ça et puis on voit
maintenant
par exemple l'année dernière ce site qui
se mêlent movie diusse a mis sur le
marché dont ils ont été achetés par
intel petite clé usb ça coûte 79 dollars
vous pouvez en brancher plusieurs sur un
progression pc avec une puissance de
calcul absolument famille d'un suspect
avec un asic
petit circuit électronique et puis plus
récemment il ya le mois dernier c'était
griffard pierre falcone technologie qui
a fabriqué un autre puce qui qui met
également sur clé usb ou vous pouvez
mettre plusieurs sur une carte la
puissance de calcul et par amine ses 5
millions de millions de calculs par
seconde
ça consomme 0 6 watts ça veut dire que
ça peut tourner sur les piles et et ça
coûte bonbon connaît pas le prix mais
c'est vraisemblablement didot là aussi
on pouvait dire que tous ces systèmes en
fait sont pas vraiment intelligent parce
que en fait il doit être entraînée à
faire des tâches que les êtres humains
saft a déjà mais dans mon labo on est en
train de développer ce que j'appellerais
des systèmes vraiment un véritable
intelligence avec mes collaborateurs n'a
de retrouver un album qui s'appelle just
jazz parce que c'est les quatre
inventeurs jake amnesty mon estime et ce
malgré ma capable de trouver des
patterns qui se répète dans les données
n'importe quelles données données sans
supervision du tout donc on n'a pas
besoin d'avoir un instructeur pas de
besoin donc de supervision et on a
réussi à faire tourner ses albums sur ce
qu'on appelle un stg ans et le petit
cercle un programme qui coûte à peu près
cela est donc là ma petite société vous
souvenez de ce pragmatique dans le gie a
été acheté par notre société californien
en 2007 qui a obtenu la licence pour
mettre ces idées dans des puces et
l'idée actuellement c'est dans l'année
qui viennent de fabriquer un puce qui
s'appelle à kid avec des millions de mu
avant des milliards de synapses dedans
et avec l'apprentissage sur l'opus donc
à ça à mon avis ça pouvait être très
important alors tous et plus à 10 $ qui
avec un puissance de calcul faramineux
qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'est ce que ça va
faire
eh bien à mon avis avoir un impact sur
l'emploi qui est considérable beaucoup
de tâches actuellement faits par les
êtres humains peut être remplacé pour un
circuit qui coûte 10 lot detected aura
par exemple un des chauffeurs on va
avoir des cheveux des voitures autonomes
bientôt surtout maintenant pendant des
puces à 10 dollars mais plein de métiers
actuels vont à mon avis si l'on ne vont
pas disparaître
ça va être très difficile de maintenir
des emplois
mais c'est pas uniquement des
détachements ouvriers par exemple les
tâches de spécialistes mais si une
classification de l'image de radio g par
exemple baumann au grand public en
français ou pas c'est fait mieux par une
machine par le meilleur que brad may
aspects se disent pas ce qu'on peut
regrouper l'expertisé de pointe du
spécialiste
seul circuit donc potentiellement c'est
catastrophique on pouvait avoir un 30%
de la dd boulot qu'on pouvait
disparaître à cause de ça et donc
potentiellement c'est gravissime mais en
fait je pense qu'une solution
d'institutions et un revenu de base
inconditionnel pour tous est une idée
qui est très d'actualité en ce moment en
fait ces risques pour la preuve sap est
revenu de base ou betty king comme donc
index et vous trouverez des dizaines de
présentations depuis deux ans tout le
monde en parle 1
ce que je voulais vous poser le
présenter ici que c'est que des problème
principal c'est que comme on la finance
comme on va trouver de l'argent pour le
payer et bien c'est là au monde on
intérêt pour l'économie joue un rôle
parce que je vais vous proposer trois
mètres différents qui marchent à mon
avis qui peut être combinée l'un c'est
un système de taxation négative
deuxièmement création monétaire par les
banques centrales
et troisièmement une taxe globale sur
les transactions financières donc déjà
revenu de base et taxation négative
l'idée c'est qu'un bon là c'est la
distribution des revenus en france
milliers d euros par mois pas pour
sont-ils vous voyez ici que à peu près
10% de la population en france n'a pas
de revenu à juge pas les gens à l'âge de
travailler
et puis le montant augmente et puis bon
bah est à peu près 2% des gens qui
gagnent plus de 10000 euros par mois
j'ai pas tracer la suite ce qu'il ya des
gens qui gagnent des millions par mois
mais ce qu'est ce qui est vraiment
important revenu médian
c'est ça veut dire que ici un à peu près
la moitié de la population gagne au
moins au moins 1700 euros et l'autre
moitié bien gagnent moins de 2700 alors
taxation négatif ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'on va instaurer un revenu
de base à 600 euros par exemple pour
tout le monde et puis ensuite on va
payer 30% sur tout ce qu'on ne gagne qu
elle que soit deux sources
et ça donne cette courbe rouge qui a un
point d'équilibré quand on en gagne 2
millions euros on a 600 euros de revenu
de base mais on paye si son yoyo en
taxes 30% qui veut dire qui on est et on
est neutres et ça veut dire que 61 % de
la population en fait tout est argent du
système de taxation
le miracle c'est que en fait ce système
j'étais les calculs celle d'auch sauf
que c'est totalement autofinançons les
39 qui gagnent plus de 2 millions euros
par mois en payant juste 30% de ce noeud
sur plus de 2000 euros financent
entièrement grèce
donc c'est un système qui ne coûte rien
c'est un pur mans puis au mans système
purement redistributif bon on va pas
payer des infirmières et les les
enseignants avec ça mais qu au moins
comme ça tout le monde peut avoir
quelque chose en fait l'idée d'un flat
tax de d1 taxe à 30% fixe c'est a déjà
été voté par nos députés
on voit de d'octobre dernier mais
uniquement pour les revenus qui vient du
capital des loyers des dividendes issus
comme ça ça a déjà été voté donc tout ce
que je vous le demande c'est qu'on
applique même chose à tous les sources
de revenus en particulier des salaires
ok donc ça c'est une chose mais l'autre
chose c'est que en fait je vous ai donné
l'exemple
de ski ce qu'on obtient avec 30 % de
taxes ça donne 600 euros par mois vous
voulez plus vous remonter le taux de
taxation 40% ça donnerait 800 euros par
mois à tout le monde de base 50% c'est
un million euros par mois pas pour
chacun et tout ça s'est toujours
autofinancée toujours les 39% mais plus
avec les revenus de plus élevé qui
payent pour le reste pas mal deuxième
idée revenu de base
prié par le créa sont demandés par les
banques centrales là j'ai pris des
chiffres très officielle de la banque
centrale européen
ah ça c'est depuis depuis trois ans de
sous la présidence de mario draghi
tous les mois la banque centrale a
acheté entre 60 et 80 milliards de de
d'action des choses comme ça sur les
marchés financiers ça fait un total de
plus de 200 de 2200 milliards d'euros
c'est de l'argent qui a été créée de
toutes pièces qui est utilisé pour
renflouer renflouer les marchés
financiers
ça veut dire c'est l'équivalent de 6
6686 europa personnes dans la zone euro
et on est nombreux en et 330 millions
200 euros par mois
comment ça se fait qu'on a donné à mario
draghi l'ex directeur européen de golman
sachs droit de financer ont cloué des
marchés financiers pourquoi on n'a pas
tout simplement de donner cet argent aux
citoyens dernière idée
c'est un impôt universelle sur les
transactions financières ça c'est une
idée c'est mon dada depuis 2010
je passe pas mal de temps chaque année à
éplucher les chiffres dus à des
ressources utiles c'est le pain qui
compile les normes document de 500 pages
dans lesquelles on a des chiffres sur
les transactions dont 24 pays
et là je les ai regrouper pour les états
unis etc de total
c'est par an et c'est stable depuis une
bonne dizaine d'années 11 millions de
milliards de transactions dollars par an
et ce chiffre n'est même pas le vrai
chiffre parce que ça c'est 24 tél il n'y
a que cinq pays dans la zone euro il y
en a 19 y compris le luxembourg qui fait
beaucoup de transactions aussi et il ya
certains actes gigantesque qui ne sont
pas dans les chiffres n'ont plus aucun
screen grenoble aux etats unis 4
milliards de transactions par an il est
tout à fait possible que le vrai chiffre
est peut-être le double alors mon idée
et je les fais un calcul année dernière
où j'ai dit bon si vous en voulez donner
un revenu de base à chaque personne sur
la planète 1 50% delà du salaire médian
dans tous les pays du monde
en france ce sera donc 850 euros mwh at
il là médian en afrique ce sera une
dizaine de dollars
bien évidement de les salaires sont
différents mais là dedans mais en
présence de total j'obtiens le chiffre
certes impressionnant de 10,6 ville
milliers de milliards de dollars et non
mais c'est rappelez vous c'est moins de
0,1 pour cent des transactions
financiers on pouvait très bien dire on
va taxer toutes les transactions paypal
tous des marchés 0 bigre 1% et tout le
monde sur la planète aurait un revenu de
base
pourquoi on ne fait pas eh bien je
résume les points clés je vous ai montré
qu on a déjà des puces à 10 dollars
équipé de 10 plaintes qui sont déjà en
train de remplacer beaucoup de boulot à
mon avis ça va devenir encore pied avec
des avec ce que je fais moi parce que
c'est plus de des puces vont être encore
encore plus intelligent donc la
conséquence de tout ça potentiellement
est catastrophique chômage massif des
jambons on ad on a déjà voté président
français d'être pierre canto et à 30% de
la population qui ne peut même pas payer
les loyers etc
mais il ya une solution je suis persuadé
que un revenu de base règle tous les
problèmes et je vous ai montré trois
façons pour le faire qui peut être
combiné il ya aucun problème on peut le
financer donc
je pense que en conclusion il faut pas
avoir peur des ces nouvelles
technologies
c'est en fait c'est un grand plus on va
pouvoir passer sa vie à faire de ce
qu'on a envie de faire plutôt que de
gratter de l'argent en cherchant de
boulots payés et donc pour moi le monde
de notre raison à nos enfants pouvait
être bien mieux
celle qu'on vit aujourd'hui merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]